[Музика]
не всі з приблизно 890 000 загалом
Люди
можливо прийшов минулого року і
залишиться і з іншого боку
у нас близько 35 відсотків випадків
люди, які після a
належний процес №
право залишатися з нами тоді воно належить
дотримання закону, який ми
скажіть цим людям, що вони наші
ми повинні знову залишити країну
cdu і csu міжособистісні
спілкування для нас одне з головних
розігруючи роль, показуючи її обличчя
тому повна завіса знаходиться на
невідповідні нам, їх слід заборонити
буття
скрізь, де це можливо юридично
не належить
і відверто, якщо a
Угода про вільну торгівлю з США
Штати Америки сотні тисяч в
але виводить Німеччину на дорогу
ці жорстокі бомбардування на а
яблука майже немає публічного
викликати протест, тоді щось правильно
не з політичними стандартами
тому такий захоплюючий і такий цікавий
оскільки національні регуляторні органи
обіцяє процвітання для всіх
навіть у часи цифровізації
зараз у ці тижні та місяці
інтенсивно про своє рішення
четверта кандидатура канцлера
думка про це спрямована на мене
сказав, що ти повинен ти повинен ти повинен
шикувати
це мене дуже зворушило, але
так і додам
в такі часи
ти повинен ти повинен допомогти мені
[Оплески]